Robin Thicke breaks his silence after
the passing of his father Alan the
blurred line singer told the LA Times
his dad was always a gentleman and
called him the greatest man I ever met
and added quote the good thing was that
he was beloved and had closure I'm here
outside of Providence st. Joseph's
Medical Center where et has learned that
Alan Thicke died today of a heart attack
he was 69 years old shortly after news
of the growing pains star's death broke
celebrities flooded social media with
their reaction and their sorrow
including Candace Cameron Bure who had
recently worked with Alan on season two
of fuller house Candace whose brother is
Alan's growing pains co-star Kirk
Cameron of course took to Instagram
writing I'm sad beyond words that Alan
Thicke has passed away I've known you
since I was 8 years old and so glad I
had the pleasure of working with you
again so recently on fuller house you
were a part of my family and hockey
family you will be greatly missed
another reaction was Bob Saget's also
from fuller house he said so sad is the
passing of Alan Thicke such a good
husband father brother and friend he
will be deeply missed
Paula Patton the ex-wife of Alan's son
Robin Thicke shared a heartfelt quote
from mother Teresa about how precious
life is
most of the fuller house cast weighing
in quickly on Twitter Lori Loughlin said
I'm so sad to hear about the passing of
Alan Thicke another TV icon Larry King
tweeting so sorry to hear of the passing
of Alan Thicke a wonderful talent a
wonderful man Marlee Matlin tweeted I am
saddened at the news of Alan Thicke's
passing my daughter and I just saw him
rest in peace dear friend and gentleman
and Chaka Khan also shared condolences
to the family of Alan Thicke if ever
there was a time celebs are thinking
about our mortality 2016 is it
you